CHARLES NESSON: Identity.
In cyberspace, everyone has an identity.
You have an identity.
You make it.
You create it.
In an interplay, in an online group of people within a small group
environment, you express your identity by what you say and how you say it.
I think of it in the way that I think about poker.
Both poker and jury process play around a round table
with people who are legally equal.
The poker tournament starts with everyone
having the same number of chips, and the actual unfolding
of the game not being so structured, that you
can tell how it's going to come out.
Unless you actually indulge the interplay of the players.
Your play will affect my play, as mine will affect yours.
And in a discussion, what I assert, what I listen to,
the strength with which I assert it, the willingness
with which I take your point.
These are elements of play.
Poker breaks down into how frequently you
play, what games you choose to enter.
And once you've chosen to enter, how aggressively you play.
One form of poker player is very cautious about entering,
chooses battles very carefully, but when a battle is undertaken,
it's waged with assertiveness.
On the other end of the spectrum, it's possible to be somebody who kind of has
something to say about everything.
Let's see what this hand, produces.
But doesn't actually commit very much, and so doesn't risk very much.
Well, out of that balance of play, your identity as understood by the others
around the table takes shape, and your force
is experienced by the others in how you express.